[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara hallweg guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen Norbert Lehmann ist auch
wieder dabei für den Sport schön guten
Abend auch von mir es gibt neues von der
Bahn
überraschendes streikende die
lockführergewerkschaft GDL verhandelt
wieder mit der Bahn ab Montag früh
können Pendler aufatmen
der nächste protestsamstag in
Deutschland allein in Düsseldorf
demonstrieren rund 100.000 Menschen
gegen Rechtsextremismus und die
AFD und das nächste Ziel im Blick die
Handballer verpassen den Einzug ins em
Finale können sich aber morgen für
Olympia
qualifizieren wir beginnen mit der
Nachricht die viele Bahnreisende
erleichtern dürfte ab Montag können
Pendler wohl wieder ihre gewohnten
Verbindungen nutzen die Lockführer
beenden ihren Streik vorzeitig ihre
Gewerkschaft kehrt zurück an den
Verhandlungstisch
ursprünglich geplant war der
lockführerstreik bis Montagabend 18 Uhr
jetzt sollen die Züge schon früher
wieder rollen im Güterverkehr ab
morgenabend 18 Uhr im Personenverkehr ab
Montag früh um 2 Uhr mehr von Christoph
desterell keine Züge keine Fahrgäste
doch schon ab Montag früh und nicht erst
am Abend dürfte es an Bahnhöfen wieder
lebhafter Aussehen Zugreisende können
auf einen geschmeidigen Wochenstart
hoffen Bahn und Gewerkschaft wieder auf
etwas Sympathie dann kann ich am Montag
beruhigt auf Arbeit fahren ja war schon
etwas länger wo ich sonst dreiviertel
Stunde brauchst du anderthalb Stunde bis
zwei Stunden man ist da schon so ein
bisschen abgestumpft irgendwie also wenn
nicht gestreigt wird ist es ja auch
unzuverlässig ist ja nicht so dass es
dann alles gut ist irgendwas muss
passiert sein in diesen letzten
Streiktagen dass die streitäne GDL und
Bahn schon in in der Nacht ein paar
verhandlungsbrocken abgeräumt haben und
etwa darüber einig sind dass es noch im
März eine
inflationsausgleichsprämie von 1500 €
für unsere Mitarbeitenden gibt außerdem
wurde auch vereinbart über
Arbeitszeitmodelle zu verhandeln also
über den großen Zankapfel die GDL
kommentiert zufrieden insbesondere die
Verhandlungsbereitschaft der DB zur
arbeitszeitabsenkung für Schichtarbeiter
ist zentral bedeutsam
dass es jetzt überhaupt klappt mit dem
Reden das sei auch dem öffentlichen
Groll auf den Streik zu verdanken meint
der Fahrgastverband ich denke der Druck
ist doch so groß dass man sich jetzt
wirklich einmal überlegt wie man da
zusammenkommt und wie man da einen
vernünftigen Tarifabschluss hinbekommt
gesprochen wird vom 5 februar bis zum 3
März etwa ein Monat um eine vollständige
Lösung im Tarifstreit zu finden der
weall gilt Friedenspflicht bedeutet ein
Mon mon garantiert ohne Streiks und wenn
alles klappt auch darüber
hinaus Stefanie rein steht am
Hauptbahnhof in Berlin stefhanie wie
sind die Chancen dass GDL und Bahn sich
jetzt
zusammenraufen na ja sie sind ein
Schrittchen oder vielleicht auch einen
ganzen Schritt auf diesem Weg gegangen
die Gespräche die jetzt dazu geführt
haben die seien sehr offen sehr
konstruktiv gewesen vertraulich auch und
es sei alles auf den Tisch gekommen und
das Resultat ist das jetzt wieder
gesprochen wird es soll jetzt unter
Ausschuss der Öffentlichkeit sein das
heißt es soll nichts mehr nach draußen
dringen und bei Bedarf kann jede der
beiden Tarifpartner jeder der beiden
Tarifpartner ein Moderator dazu ziehen
das soll verhindern dass es wieder so
ruckelig wird dass es sich komplett
verhagt das wichtige Wort des Tages ist
aber Friedenspflicht die gilt nämlich ab
jetzt bis zum 3 März soll ja verhandelt
werden solange wird nicht gestreigt die
Bahn wird morgen tausende Züge umplanen
hat sie heute gesagt damit die alle
halbwegs da sind wo sie am Montag früh
gebraucht werden denn ab Montag soll
alles wieder richtig sein es soll noch
ein kleines bisschen ruckeln sagte die
Bahnsprecherin das kann schon passieren
aber im Prinzip soll es ab Montag wieder
geschmeidig laufen und dann sicher bis
zum 3 März danke schön für diese
Information aus Berlin danke Stefanie
Hein auch an diesem Wochenende gibt es
bundesweit Demonstrationen gegen
Rechtsextremismus insgesamt in mehr als
300 Dörfern und Städten sagt das Bündnis
zusammen gegen Rechts heute kamen z.B in
Kiel nach Polizeiangaben mehr als 11000
Menschen zusammen 25 000 waren es in
ossnerbrück rund 100.000 in Düsseldorf
Jan Hofer war dort alle
zusammenen den Faschismus Düsseldorf am
Mittag ein breites Bündnis von Parteien
Gewerkschaften und anderen
Organisationen hatte aufgerufen zur
Demonstration
entremis und gegen die
AFD ich möchte eigentlich gegen diese
braune Suppe
mitmschieren weil ich es ganz
entsetzlich finde deswegen stehe ich
hier weil ich den rechten zeigen möchte
dass man keine Angst vor ihnen haben
braucht wenn wir gemeinsam draußen
stehen und gegen sie angehen die Sorge
und die Frustration über die Entwicklung
die politischen in Deutschland dass die
das ist für mich unvorstellbar mein
Vater war noch
Kriegskind Randen durch die Stadt zu
einer Kundgebung auf den Rheinwiesen
laut Polizei sind es hier dann etwa
100.000 Menschen deutlich mehr als von
den Veranstaltern
erwartet ich find es ganz bewundernswert
wie viele Menschen noch auf der Brücke
sind wie viele noch unterwegs sind und
dass sich so viele trotz Bahnstreik auf
dem Weg gemacht haben mir geht da so ein
bisschen das Herz auf und es zeigt ja
auch man ist nicht alleine mit der
Meinung während man vorher vielleicht
dachte so ja alle regen sich so ein
bisschen auf aber keiner macht was und
jetzt sieht man es in so VI viele Leute
hier das schon sehr cool tatsächlich war
es heute so dass ich fast irgendwie so
trendchen in den Augen hatte weil ich
das Gefühl habe das ist jetzt so ein
Signal was brauch ein Protest aus der
Mitte der Gesellschaft Bund laut und so
bilanziert ist am Ende die Polizei
völlig
friedlich Bundeskanzler Scholz begrüßte
die zahlreichen Demos für die Demokratie
nie wieder das fordere die Wachsamkeit
aller sagte Scholz heute am
internationalen Holokaust Gedenktag vor
genau 79 Jahren befreite die Rote Armee
das Konzentrations und Vernichtungslager
Auschwitz allein dort hatten die
Nationalsozialisten mehr als eine
Million Menschen ermordet nur noch
wenige Überlebende können davon
berichten so wie der 92-Jährige Bogdan
partnikowski Natalie Steger hat ihn
getroffen bogdan batnikowski ist einer
von den wenigen Überlebenden die noch
einmal den schweren Weg zurück Auschwitz
Birkenau gehen zur Erinnerung an die
Verbrechen der deutschen wir haben Bokan
bnikowski zuvor in Warschau getroffen er
ist 12 als ih die Nazis in die Hölle von
Auschwitz deportieren er wird von der
Mutter weggerissen fragt wann er wieder
frei sein werde der Koo hat freudig
gekichert in Freiheit seht ihr diese
Schornsteine da nur so durch den Kamin
kommt man in die Freiheit es gib kein
Auschwitz mehr als eine Million Menschen
haben die Deutschen hier getötet die
meisten Opfer waren Juden auschwitz
steht weltweit für eine Maschinerie des
Mordens die Gedenkfeier zum Tag der
Befreiung auch ein mahnen die Jüdin
Halina bienbaum erinnert an das Leid in
der Ukraine und in ihrem Land
Israel die terroristischen barbarischen
Angriffe der Hamas und Krieg von allen
Seiten
es fallen die Töchter und Söhne von den
wenigen Überlebenden der
SCH gegen das Vergessen boknikowski
findet trotz des Erlebten versöhnliche
Worte wir müssen an diejenigen erinnern
die uns ermordet
haben dürfen aber nicht in Hass Leben
gegenüber den heutigen
Menschen sagt der dem die Deutschen die
Kindheit nahmen
die aktuelle Lage in Deutschland macht
vielen Unternehmern sorgen mehr als 50
große Firmen haben jetzt einen
gemeinsamen Appell unterzeichnet sie
verlangen von der Politik einen klaren
Rahmen für den klimafreundlichen Umbau
der Wirtschaft und sie warnen dass
rechtsextreme Kräfte die Demokratie und
die wirtschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit
Deutschlands bedrohten zu den
Unterzeichnern gehören etwa die Deutsche
Telekom Puma Miele tüssengrup und
Ikea Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht BSW erst
seit knapp drei Wochen gibt's die Partei
offiziell heute in Berlin ist ihr erster
Bundesparteitag Gelegenheit also zu
zeigen wofür BSW überhaupt steht die
Partei gibt sich USA und EU kritisch sie
will die Migration deutlich begrenzen
und die Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
beenden den Mittelstand möchte sie
stärken und etwa verbrennerautos
unbefristet weiter nutzen in dasü rechts
links Schema passt das alles nicht
Christiane
hübscher die meisten hier haben sich
vorher noch nie gesehen es ist eng und
voll im ehemaligen Kino in Ostberlin
dass sich das Bündnis SAR Wagenknecht
für den Gründungsparteitag ausgesucht
hat etwa 4 ne Mitglieder kommen zur
Premiere viele von ihnen exlinke ich
habe wirklich sehr mit der Linken
gefremdet die letzten Monate eigentlich
schon die letzten zwei Jahre dazu hat
das Mobbing gegen sarwang nicht
beigetragen aber auch eine Entfremdung
inhaltlich und auch personell
insbesondere was die Bundes eben angeht
andere wurden erst durch Wagenknecht
politisiert dann habe ich gesagt okay
das ist jetzt eigentlich die Zeit jetzt
könnst du dich wirklich auch mal
politisch engagieren kannst du
eigentlich was zurückgeben ich hab keine
politischen Erfahrung ich hab denke ich
eine Menge Lebenserfahrung immer im
Scheinwerferlicht das politpaar
Wagenknecht und lafontain er hat einst
die Linke gegründet sie hat sie am Ende
gesprengt ihre neue Partei ruft sie zur
Disziplin auf wir sind keine linke 20
und das muss auch für unseren Umgang
miteinander gelten lasst uns eine Partei
des Miteinanders werden und nicht eine
Partei der Intriegen und des
postengeschachers wie alle anderen
Wagenknecht bekommt viel Applaus für
ihre Rede in der sie die Ampel erneut
als dümmste Regierung Europas beschimpft
die junge Partei hat noch keinen
einzigen Landesverband gegründet will
aber schon im Juni zur Europawahl
antreten um dort einen Rückbau der EU zu
fordern wir wollen eine EU die nur das
erledigt was sie wirklich besser kann
deswegen müssen wir der EU auch in den
Arm fallen wenn sie etwa in Kommunen
hinein regiert einstimmig beschließt der
Parteitag das
europawahlprogramm am Abend will das
Bündnis seine Kandidaten für die
Europaliste
wählen Andrea Maurer beobachtet für uns
diese parteitagspremiere wen will das
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht
ansprechen ja angesprochen werden sollen
hier vor allem Menschen die wie SAR
wagenk es sagt sich politisch heimatlos
fühlen und Alternativen suchen bislang
vor allem bei der AFD die AFD ist ganz
klar politische Gegnerin ihre
Wählerinnen und Wähler sind aber auch
Zielgruppe des BSW das BSW stellt sich
klar an die Seite der wütenden Bauern an
die Seite derjenigen die Migration
begrenzen wollen an die Seite derjenigen
die glauben Verhandlungen mit Russland
seinen sofort möglich wenn nur die
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine
eingestellt würden das Bündnis versucht
hier eine doppelte Positionierung als
Alternative alternativ zur Ampel und
Alternative zur AFD das
gesellschaftliche Klima ist für diese
neue Partei dabei durchaus günstig denn
die Ampel ist schwach und macht viele
Menschen wütend die AFD ist stark und
macht vielen Menschen Angst möglich dass
in dieser Gemengelage im Superwahljahr
2024 eine Art populistischer
Überbietungswettbewerb entsteht denn
auch die vermeintlichen Lösungen die das
BSW hier anbietet sind vor allem erstmal
eins einfach vielen Dank Andrea Maurer
aus
Berlin wegen des Verdachts einige seiner
Mitarbeiter könnten am Terrorangriff der
Hamas auf Israel beteiligt gewesen sein
Gerät das un-hilfswerk für
palästinensische Flüchtlinge zunehmend
unter Druck nach den USA haben auch
Kanada Australien und Italien ihre
Zahlungen an das Hilfswerk ausgesetzt
das Auswärtige Amt in Berlin äußerte
sich zutiefst besorgt wie es aber auch
darauf hin wie wichtig die Hilfe der
UN-Organisation für Palästinenser sei
wie den Menschen in Gaza geholfen werden
kann und wie eine Zukunft in der Region
aussehen könnte darum ging es auch bei
der Reise der Außenministerin nach
Jordanien in Aman sprach bbor mit ihrem
Kollegen safadi Deutschland liefert
derzeit Medikamente und medizinisches
Material an Jordanien damit sollen
Bedürftige in Gaza versorgt
werden Ex-US-Präsident Donald Trump ist
erneut zu einer Entschädigungszahlung
verurteilt worden wegen Verläumdung
geklagt hatte die amerikanische Autorin
Caroll die heute 80-Jährige hatte Trump
wegen sexueller Nötigung verklagt und
Recht bekommen danach hatte er sie
mehrfach über Jahre der Lüge bezichtigt
nun muss Trump gut 83 Millionen Dollar
zahlen absolut lächerlich findet er das
und will Rechtsmittel
einlegen es gibt zu wenig Pflegekräfte
in Deutschland das ist bekannt das
Statistische Bundesamt hat aber jetzt
berechnet wie groß das Problem in den
kommenden Jahren werden könnte demnach
brauchen Pflegedienste Heime und
Kliniken bis
2029 rund
2,15 Millionen Pflegekräfte das wären
rund 460 000 mehr als schon jetzt
benötigt werden überall wird Personal
für morgen gesucht das Klinikum in
Magdeburg zeigt wie es vielleicht
gelingen kann Lana
uhmann Aktionstag im Klinikum Magdeburg
die Ausbildung zur Pflegekraft wird
vorgestellt zwei Dutzend junger Leute im
Alter von 16 bis Mitte 20 wollen sich
einen Eindruck von diesem Beruf
verschaffen guten Morgen herzlich
willkommen am Klinikum unter den
Interessenten ganz rechts in der Ecke
ist Anthony ihn verbindet viel mit
diesem Krankenhaus meine Mama hat in der
Pflege gearbeitet mein Vater meine Oma
und ich kenne dieses Krankenhaus hier
auch schon sehr lange pul Pulsmessen
reanimieren vieles dürfen sie heute
austesten das Klinikum 23 Fachbereiche
und kann sich so als attraktiver
Arbeitgeber zeigen man spürt ein gutes
Klima auf den Stationen obwohl aktuell
80 Pflegekräfte fehlen und deshalb
Betten gesperrt worden besonders
natürlich betroffen sind Spezialbereiche
wie die Intensivmedizin wir wollen mit
solchen Aktionstagen natürlich auf uns
aufmerksam machen und wir wollen
natürlich oder haben natürlich dann in
diesen Bereichen auch spezielle Stellen
etabliert die aubis sowie auch neue
Kollegen binden sollen Z
Ansprechpersonen die den neuen mit Rat
und Tat zur Seite stehen Verantwortung
Teilen ist die Strategie dahinter der
Rundgang ist beendet Anthonys Fazit ist
hab mir alles gefallen also ich würde
tatsächlich dran bleiben ja das Klinikum
Magdeburg ist proaktiv kreativ hat sogar
seine azubistellen aufgestockt 120 sind
derzeit in Ausbildung und hoffentlich so
die Pflegeleitung bleiben auch alle als
fertige
pflegekraftäatrie wer hat da so
Paris Stadt der Liebe des luouvre und
des Eifelturms ohnehin schon eine der
meist besuchten Städte Europas im Juli
dürften noch viel mehr Menschen dorthin
strömen zum größten Sportevent der Welt
den Olympischen Sommerspielen was
geplant ist und wo es noch haakt jetzt
sech Monate vor der Eröffnungsfeier dazu
Anne
Arend im Herzen der Stadt statt im
Stadion wird Paris die Sportwelt im Juli
empfangen eine Parade sechs Kil lang auf
der SC pierre rabadon ist der Olympia
beauftragte im Pariser Rathaus er
rechnet mit mehr als 15 Millionen Gästen
während der
Spiele wir müssen zusätzliche
Infrastrukturen schaffen die Ankunft der
Zuschauer organisieren ich bin
zuversichtlich aber auch demütig weil
noch viel zu tun
ist noch ragen die Baukräne in den
Himmel das olympische Dorf Sportstätten
Schwimmbäder stehen kurz vor der
Fertigstellung besonders unter Druck ist
das Verkehrsnetz veraltet nicht
barrierefrei überlastet mehr Züge sollen
im Sommer eingesetzt und dafür die
Preise erhöht werden die Spiele sorgen
nicht nur für Zuspruch in der
Stadt ich hau ab das wird das totale
Chaos
hier ich glaube den Touristen wird es
gefallen aber ich ich mag keine
Menschenmassen einent diehe Kräfte vor
eine enorme Aufgabe stellt die Polizei
demonstriert bereits für Prämien und
bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen wir geben alles um
diese Spiele abzusichern aber unsere
Leute brauchen auch
Planungssicherheit se Monate bleiben
noch um die Stadt fit zu machen für
einen olympiasommer vor
postkartenkulisse ja aber jetzt erstmal
zur Handball EM in Deutschland das
Daumendrücken gestern Abend hat nichtich
geholfen Wunder von Köln blieb aus ja
aber das dhbteam das war ja wirklich
ganz nah dran Topleistung im Halbfinale
gegen Weltmeister Dänemark fast das
ganze Spiel auf Augenhöhe am Ende mit 26
Z 29 verloren aber eine Medaille ist ja
noch drin morgen beim Spiel und Platz 3
und die Olympia Quali dazu ein erstes
beschnuppern mit dem morgigen Gegner
gibt's heute schon beim offiziellen
Medientermin aller vier Halbfinalisten
eine halbe Stunde lang stehen heute
Trainer und alle spielerrede und Antwort
durchaus bemerkenswert mit Blick auf die
enge Taktung der Spiele bei Deutschlands
Spielmacher Juri Knorr sitzt der Stachel
der Enttäuschung auch am Tag danach noch
immer sehr tief das werfe ich mir vor
dass ich nicht weiß nicht ich mich auch
so ein bisschen von meiner von meiner
Angst auch irgendwie hab leben lassen
vor dem Moment sollten morgen dann
Bronze und die Olympia Qualifikation
herausspringen wäre sein Frust sicher
schnell
verflogen im Spitzenspiel der Fußball
buundesliga hat der VfB den dritten
Tabellenplatz verteidigt hier die
bisherigen Ergebnisse des 19 Spieltags
stuttgartleipzig 5:2 augsburg- München
2:3 Bremen Freiburg 3:1 wolfsburg-köln
1:1 ebenso Hoffenheim gegen Heidenheim
das Abendspiel Leverkusen gegen Gladbach
bereits gestern Frankfurt Mainz 1:0
Blick auf die Tabelle Leverkusen bleibt
vorne knapp dahinter München dann
unverändert Stuttgart Leipzig und
Dortmund und am tabellenend Köln einen
Platz hoch auf 16 vor Mainz und
Schlusslicht
Darmstadt das Abendspiel Leverkusen
Gladbach ausfühlich bei uns zu sehen im
Aktuellen Sportstudio ab 22:30 Uhr in
der ZDF Mediathek und um 23 Uhr im ZDF
zu Gast das deutschees slalomas Linus
strassa Arina sabalenka hat ihren Titel
bei den Australien Open verteidigt die
Weißrussin gewann sverin gegen die
Chinesin jinven J mit 6:3 und 6 zur Z
zur skiflug WM in badmitterndorf da hat
Andreas Wellinger Silber geholt der
28-Jährige sprang im letzten Durchgang
starke 229 m und verbesserte sich damit
von Rang 4 auf 2 WM Gold ging an
Österreichs Topfavoriten Stefan Kraft
rel WM in Altenberg die Frauen heute
ohne Medaillen dafür aber die Männer
erfolgreich im Doppelsitzer holten
Tobias alt und Tobias wendel Bronze ja
und im Einzel fuhr Max Langenhahn zu
seinem ersten
Weltmeistertitel Max Langenhahn ganz
oben endlich er war programmiert auf
Gold nach ze Siegen in den letzten 11
Weltcups war diese Fahrt im zweiten Lauf
Angriff pur jede Kurve saß mit dieser
triumfahrt bisher alle mit das jetzt so
kommt besser hät man nicht schreiben
können wir sind super glücklich ch da
kann man wirklich nur seinen Hut oder
seine Mütze abnehmen sagt
bundestrainerbertch bei seiner letzten
WM er hört zum Saisonende auf sein Sohn
Felix hat dafür noch mal alles
rausgeholt an Erfahrung und Kampfgeist
und WM Bronze gewonnen der 34-Jährige
hat allen noch mal gezeigt und morgen
wieder jede Menge Wintersport bei uns im
ZDF live ab 10:20 danke schön nbert die
Nacht wird kalt der Sonntag sonnig
Details hat gleich Katja horneffer vi:4
Uhr begrüßt Sie Christian sieverers im
heutejournal und wir sind morgen wieder
da einen schönen Abend noch und
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend heute strahlte die Sonne
über Deutschland und auch über dem
westlichen Mitteleuropa sowie über der
iberischen Halbinsel gut zu erkennen
sind auch die Schneeflächen in den Alpen
auf diesem Satellitenbild sehen sie aber
noch mehr denn westlich von Afrika sehen
Sie hier Sahara Staub und der wird
morgen angetrieben von diesem Tief bei
den kapwerdischen Inseln weiter nach
Norden geführt erreicht dann Westeuropa
Großbritannien und vielleicht sehen sie
auch in Norddeutschland ein paar von
diesen Schleierwolken angetrieben durch
den Saharastaub die meisten aber von uns
profitieren von hochenne und auch heute
Nacht ist es meist klar es bildet sich
etwas Nebel in den flusstäln
Süddeutschlands und über Norddeutschland
verlassen uns Hochnebelfelder ostwärts
es kann glatt sein auf Straßen und
Gehwegen denn die Temperaturen sinken
auf plus 2 bis -5° die Höchstwerte
morgen liegen zwischen 5 und 11° und der
Tag morgen wird fast noch sonniger als
heute ein paar Nebelfelder gibt's in
Süddeutschland und über Norddeutschland
dieser angesprochenen Hochnebelfelder
ganz ähnlich mit ruhigem winterwitter
startet dann auch die neue Woche bei
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 6 und 13°.
schönes
Wochenende